sam congratulations we were kind of
ignoring your game it looked like white
was a little
a tiny bit maybe not much better after
18 moves could you have imagined that
four or five moves later your opponent
is resigning
yeah i mean
the position was pretty much equal and
then maybe he had a slight advantage but
i was trying to find a way to equalize
and then he played this really bad move
king g2
i'm not only equalizing but i'm just
close to winning right after it
incredible gift what do you think
happened
uh well if we go to that position
so a5 so the point of this position is
if white plays e5
and let's say i play bishop takes e5
white plays bishop takes b7 rook b8 c6
and that's a very annoying c pawn
well it can support it with knight b5
they're exchange sacrifices followed by
bishop f4
so brook takes e5 and bishop f4 coming
yeah so the key after e5 is to play
knight d7 with black
and now if bishop takes b7
rook b8
c6
i can go after the c punk with knight c5
and get rid of it
although knight 65 might also be good
there tactically with queen d5
so knight d7 i think he didn't realize
how important this position was after
before e5 because
it looks okay for white but king g2 just
the normal waiting move kind of clogs
his bishop on f3
and once again this move knight d7 that
looks
like a very crafty kind of move
white can mix it up maybe with e6 i was
considering that e6 f6 bishop takes b
takes b7 rook b
and this is where
you more or less get this situation
where you're
you're hunting down bishop here i think
i'll be up upon i hate that [ __ ] about
b7 it looks like you want it back on no
question about it he can move it back
and i take on c5 and play upon down
position definitely better than what he
did in the game
so let's say repeat bishop goes back to
g2 i take on c5
bishop e3
i think black's a bit better but okay
it's still a game right still play chess
exactly but then if it came to g2
[Music]
and you play this beautiful retreat
knight d7 i think yes
i didn't realize how strong it was until
i found knight e5
uh which
funny i'm just threatening to take the
opponent a2
and you're gonna go knight c3
wow there's not much you can do about it
he should definitely protect the pawn
with rugby too to keep the game going
and your attention there afterwards
uh maybe rook a6 is interesting
this bishop on f3 has been terrible wow
terrible construction sam i mean oh my
goodness yeah you should have played
bishop g2 exactly exactly one little
quiet move was it time pressure for him
also oh yeah he was spending a lot of
time in the opening but he before rook
b3 was 15 each
15 each yeah oh so you guys where you
going
oh yeah he just missed it and then he
just missed a4 and that was it and the
game is over well it's nice to get a
gift after you play a 120 140 new game
then you get a nice quickie 22 moves
with the black pieces
you gotta be feeling good right now yeah
very good
you are in clear first as well for the
moment at least there's a lot of games
ahead
four rounds left
your
thoughts about the championship overall
i'm just taking a game at a time i still
have four very difficult opponents to
play so who are your remaining opponents
uh i have linear wesley with white and
john burke and daniel with black
naradaysky yeah so you got two big games
coming up now yeah all right well get
out of here you got to prepare thank you
congratulations congratulations